[Applauso]
beh anche al tè da arrivano di
influencer no va di moda la di moda e
siamo anche per questo cosa sono i
social io mi sono chiesto più volte
questa cosa no noi siamo abituati a
vedere questi influenze che raccolgono
numeri poi vanno dagli alberghi gli
dicono detti della visibilità in cambio
tumi ospiti tre giorni magari al mare no
però i social sono uno strumento secondo
me è molto molto potente ti permettono
di fare delle cose che il mondo
dell'editoria classica non ti
permetterebbe mai di fare il tema è
l'argomento l'argomento che tratti puoi
trattare di più di trucchi puoi trattare
di lifestyle di costruzione del
bodybuilding puoi trattare di una marea
di cose io ho scelto un campo che è poco
battuto perché forse un complesso da
raccontare che è la cultura l'arte
appena noi diciamo la parola cultura
di solito parte subito un momento che è
il pomeriggio fa caldo si cade la testa
immediatamente perché pensiamo sia una
cosa pesante pensiamo sia una cosa
noiosa invece la cultura na figata
la questione come la racconti io non so
chi di voi si ricorda la storia che ha
fatto al liceo
io ho fatto il classico quindi mi hanno
fatto una testa tanta con la storia
romana e ricordo per esempio questa cosa
assurda di annibale che varcava le alpi
con gli elefanti
questa è una figata c'è un pazzo da
cartagine risale tutta la spagna
attraversa le alpi con gli elefanti
romani se ne trovano così lo capiscono
più niente vengono massacrati a questo
cos'è questa è cultura
questa è cultura
quindi con questa inconsapevolmente da
questa da questa storia di arrivare
parte un po una mia un mio sviluppo
personale che poi è il titolo del mio
cane è il nome del mio canale che il
viaggio di scoperta perché è un percorso
che costruisci la tua conoscenza della
cultura la conoscenza di te stesso
dal liceo varese vado venezia varia
venezia studiare beni culturali è però
venezia un'esperienza stranissima da
vivere perché sei in un museo all'aperto
ma allo stesso tempo è un museo vivo si
creano delle dinamiche sociali che si
creano solo a venezia a venezia trova un
lavoro molto interessante ma in un posto
proprio che di cultura e di vecchio cioè
proprio sopra un etichetta grande così
il teatro lirico
l'opera vado a lavorare alla fenice e
alla fenice scopro la musica classica
l'opera queste storie d'amore
incredibili mi innamoro tra l'altro di
una mia collega perché a forza di vedere
storie d'amore che finiscono malissimo
poi facendo tremare anche la relazione
però però è stata una relazione
potentissima e quindi mentre sono lì a
teatro continua a dirmi ma come è
possibile ma com'è possibile queste
storie sono fighissime eppure in platea
ci sono sempre solo teste bianche teste
bianche teste bianche teste bianche
teste bianche vecchie arrivo a una
consapevolezza arriva una consapevolezza
perché quando dico ai miei amici
ragazzina venite a teatro perché una
figata cioè ci sono le storie pazzesche
noi consiglio ma non so niente
no prendo questa consapevolezza per cui
la cultura a questo grande limite che è
raccontata in una maniera tale per cui
se ce l'hai la cultura la fruisce se a
monte non ce l'hai o non non c'è modo
non vengono costruiti dei ponti vado via
da venezia
ho la fortuna di andare
lavorare in un canale tematico
televisivo dove si parla appunto di
musica classica faccia produzione
cominciò a incontrare il mezzo video e
mi rendo conto che il mezzo video è
potentissimo per raccontare per unire a
delle parole con un messaggio di
contenuto forte immagini video musica
quello che poi il cinema è quello che in
origine era l'opera sua volta prendono
ma se faccio una scelta un certo punto e
mi dico ok
proviamo proviamo a mettere insieme
queste competenze che ho ea creare
qualcosa che sia mio che sia espressione
di questa mia ricerca
no perché la cultura poi se ti
interessa
cioè tu può essere appassionato anche di
altre cose e apre un canale web apre un
canale web che parlo di cultura comincia
facendo dei super riassunti dei
cataloghi delle mostre di milano perché
ero a varese ma il format non funziona
non funziona
capisco una cosa giusta che per parlare
di cultura devi parlare di persone
perché la cultura è una stratificazione
di storia di uomini no e questi uomini
gen i militari i geni artistici gen i
politici la mattina andavano in bagno
come ognuno di noi quindi capisco che
questo muro no dei geni irraggiungibile
to del merdaccia fantozziana va
abbattuto e cominciò a costruire così le
storie parlo di pittori parlo di artisti
ma non funziona ma non funziona non
funziona
a un certo punto e riprendo in mano il
mio amore per la città di venezia che se
gli dedichi spazio ti entra nelle vene
peggio del sangue e e dico ok
proviamo a parlare di venezia proviamo a
parlare di venezia cosa che non volevo
fare in realtà perché è facile
arricchirsi con venezia non so se avete
in mente quanti airbnb che ci sono in
città
no è la cosa più facile è una vetrina
potentissima parli di venezia
hai fatto bingo io non volevo farlo
questa cosa perché è una città che ha un
potenziale di comunità mostruoso non è
solo quella cosa lì e allora faccio
qualche timida pillolina da un minuto
sulla città è un certo punto racconta
una storia che a modo suo
racconta venezia ed esco dall anonimato
la storia è quella di un palazzo che c'è
sul canal grande e adesso signori quella
toccata
quando siete sul ponte dell'accademia
non so chi di voi sia pratico di venezia
però l'unico ponte di legno e li
provvisori dal 1933
guardate verso il bacino san marco avete
la grande chiesa della salute e sulla
destra c'è un palazzo stretto alto tutto
un po storto però completamente
ricoperto di marmo completamente
d'annunzio diceva che era una vecchia
cortigiana piegata sotto il peso dei
suoi gioielli e cadario cadario nel
pensiero comune è famosissimo per
maledizioni e morte tutti i proprietari
hanno fatto una bruttissima fine però un
palazzo così è strano perché il cognome
dario a venezia e cognomi veneziani
delle grandi famiglie trovi 8 10 12
palazzi con lo stesso nome di dario c'è
solo quello e comincia a interrogarmi
diventato però ci deve essere di più ci
deve essere di più sulla facciata in più
c'è scritto c'è inciso nei marmi del
basamento che c'è scritto johannes dario
urby genio che anche fighissimo giovanni
dario al genio della città il genio
della città e venezia comincio a cercare
chi è giovane dario e scopre una storia
ricchissima
siamo nel 1453 i turchi conquistano
costantinopoli capitale dell'impero
romano d'oriente fonte di riferimenti
per tutto il mondo occidentale e dalla
sera alla mattina costantinopoli
sparisce e nasce istanbul è un momento
che noi nella nostra vita per i tipi di
storie che viviamo non abbiamo ancora
visto
c'è uno swift storico potentissimo e
venezia si trova ad avere a
costantinopoli la fonte principale dei
suoi commerci perché venezia città
potentissima aveva in costantinopoli il
suo mercato di riferimento
voi dovete immaginare costantinopoli
avete l'adriatico che scende salite
avete la grecia poi all'interno dopo la
grecia si va verso i dardanelli
dardanelli stretto dei dardanelli
costantinopoli bosforo mar nero mar
d'azov russia era un punto formidabile
era dentro era difeso era all'incrocio
di tantissimi continenti avere lì la
propria base commerciale mercantile
significava da lì controllare tutto il
bacino orientale del mediterraneo
capite che quando veneziani capiscono
che costantinopoli è diventata istanbul
i turchi sono acerrimi nemici
c'è un problema e quindi si va in guerra
si va in guerra
vent'anni di guerra vent'anni guerre
venezia e disperato a un certo punto non
ha più i soldi per mantenere flotte per
mantenere equipaggi per mandare avanti
l'economia c'è tutti i mercati venezia
una città mercantile e appare il
miraggio di una di una pace una pace col
turco conquistatore chi viene mandato
dario questo signor dario mi ha mandato
questo signor dario e questo signor
dario oltre a portare con sé come dono
bellini che non è cocktail ma è un
pittore della madonna lo porta in dono
al sultano infatti se vedete c'è una
foto di momento se c'è una foto sembrano
foto un ritratto di un aumento secondo
fatto da bellini è fatto in quel momento
lì riesce dario a firmare una pace con
il turco conquistatore vantaggiosissima
e rimette in sella venezia sui commerci
in patria non capiscono più niente
pazzia cioè quando dario torna viene
accolto con il titolo di salvatore della
patria
salvatore della patria una singola
persona gli vengono dati titolo
nobiliare terre sempre bene averle e
liquidità
e con la liquidità dario cosa fa
costruisce il palazzo in canal grande e
costruisce quel palazzo che tutti
conoscono per la storia sbagliata cioè
queste morti
lui costruisce questo palazzo e sul
basamento scrive johannes dario urby
genio giovanni dario al centro della
città cioè grazie venezia firmato
giovanni dario allora lì mi si apre un
baratro sotto i piedi e scopro venezia
venezia
io vi assicuro da uno che la cerca sulle
pagine non finisce mai di dire mamma mia
scopro che lo stato longi e lo stato
autonomo più longevo di tutta europa più
di mille anni di autonomia più antico di
tutte le monarchie regnanti scopro che i
suoi domini andavano da cipro di fronte
a israele fino a crema lombardia
battevano loro più puro del mondo l'oro
zecchino lo battevano nella zecca di
venezia e cominciò con questo effetto
wow
a raccontare questa città e cosa succede
la pagina comincia ad andare bene
comincia andare molto bene questo questo
video su su cadario fa proprio uscire la
pagina dall'anonimato e succede una cosa
inaspettata l'amore che perché poi è
sempre nice parlare di amore per venezia
tutti lo possono dire tutti amano
venezia e grazie no come dire brutto
essere lister o non lo puoi fare cioè no
comincio però questo desiderio di
scoperta di ricerca nei video io in un
modo non altro lo comunico perché sono
delle figate pazzesche
se voi guardate la basilica di san marco
davanti alla basilica ci sono tre enormi
pi li porta bandiera sono delle aste
rosse ecco quei tre bilili sono il
simbolo dei tre domini veneziani che
erano cambia creda tutta creta è stata
veneziana per secoli
l'amore a
il peloponneso perché se se il partenone
adesso ve lo vedete senzatetto e perché
i veneziani durante un assedio
quando la tenera turca l'anno bombardato
il terzo e cipro
fate cipro creta il peloponneso scopro
delle cose incredibili e raccontandole
incontro i cittadini incontro i
cittadini che si trovano in un momento
difficile della loro vita di una città
sempre più spopolata una città sempre
più usata come un una vasca di grande
prima jali no e nasce un viaggio di
scoperta diventa un canale dove io
racconto il sentimento di amore che i
cittadini hanno per la loro città ed è
ed è incredibile perché vengo fermato
per strada per avere un canale da 80
mila follower su una città dove ce ne
sono 50 mila no la proporzione è molto
forte quindi vengo fermato per strada le
persone dicono racconta questa storia
racconta questa storia racconta questa
storia e quindi tutta questa cosa è una
mia storia personale però la vera forza
secondo me sta nei social perché i
social non sono che nella pagina di
stare anche score che scrocca le notti
da dormire i social sono un'occasione
sono un'occasione enorme che noi oggi
abbiamo di poter fare qualcosa che non
sia valido solo per noi perché la figata
è che questi video maturano i video che
io faccio sono maturati per tutti quanti
feedback delle persone non è più una
pagina mia è una pagina che accomuna una
comunità e allo stesso tempo racconta
venezia che luogo più bello del mondo
dove fare comunità
[Applauso]